ما الذي يحاول لافروف أن يجادل
به جيدًا ، إنه كما تقول جيك أه سيجا
لافروف ، كان وزير الخارجية الروسي
يحاول تبرير
قرار بلاده بإرسال آلاف الجنود عبر
الحدود إلى أوكرانيا المجاورة
منذ البداية ، وقد قالوا نفس
الشيء  نسمعها بشكل متزايد الآن
بينما تستعد البلاد
للاحتفال بيوم النصر لإحياء
ذكرى نهاية أه الحرب العالمية الثانية ،
تمامًا كما شكلت ألمانيا النازية
تهديدًا وجوديًا لروسيا في
الأربعينيات من القرن الماضي ، تشكل أوكرانيا مع النازيين الجدد أمك.
تعرف تهديدًا لروسيا
والروس أه الروس العرقيين في أوكرانيا
الآن المشكلة مع هذه الحجة
بالطبع هي أن أوكرانيا لا يديرها
النازيون بل يديرها رئيس يهودي
عندما واجه سيرجي لافروف
تلك الحقيقة
التي توصل إليها من أجل ذلك العداء  - مجاز سامي
مفاده أن اليهود هم المسؤولون
عن أكثر أنواع الأعمال المعادية للسامية
ونظرية المؤامرة التي تحظى
بشعبية كبيرة على الإنترنت والتي قد يكون هتلر
نفسه  كان لديهم دماء يهودية ، لذا ،
نعم ، هذا يفضح فقط ، أعتقد إلى
حد ما كيف أن الخيط
الذي يحمل تبرير روسيا
لإرسال قواتهم إلى أوكرانيا
هو حقًا أن حكومة إسرائيل
ردت على هذه التعليقات
، فقد قال رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي
نفتالي بينيت  أم
وصفتهم بالأساس على أنهم أكاذيب أه وقد
أدان أه هذه الفكرة التي أم تعلم
أن اليهود يجب أن يلاموا أه على أبشع
الجرائم التي ارتكبت بحق اليهود أه وهو
ما تعلمون كما أقول هذا هذا هذا
المجاز المعاد للسامية هذا هذا هو
غالبًا ما يتم طرحها هناك ، لذا فهي
مثيرة للاهتمام لأن إسرائيل كانت حتى
الآن تجلس كثيرًا على
الحياد عندما يتعلق الأمر بروسيا ، فهي لم
تطبق بالكامل مجموعة العقوبات الدولية التي تم فرضها ضد
أم
أه أه فرضت على موسكو
لأعمالها داخل أوكرانيا ، وهذا
رد فعل دبلوماسي حاد للغاية
كان فوريًا وسريعًا من قبل الحكومة الإسرائيلية
تجاه ما تقوم به روسيا من الخارج.
كان على الوزير أن يقول